good you guys are out now cuz you're not
watching the news too much news the news
is dark it's on 24/7 I feel like the
news is more Twisted than ever saw a
news headline the other day it said
transgender inmate impregnates female
prisoner I was like wow where is that
porn I've been watching porn my whole
life never saw a title that creative
right man the news is dark the news is
more up than poor now and it's on
everywhere every airport bar restaurant
put some porn on I think we'd be in a
better mood I was at the Amtrak station
the other day there was a news on the on
the wall on the TV and it said a man
attacks multiple people on train geez
about to get on an amp Trak put some
porn on that'd be better you then it's
like man runs a train on multiple people
all
right now I'm ready to board choo choo
yeah